the pandemic has triggered economic  hardship throughout the las vegas  community  with many families struggling to pay  their mortgage or rent  to help ease the burden move4less has  created the moving our community program  that will provide moving services from  the current residents  due to the pandemic circumstances some  of these circumstances include  loss of a job loss of a loved one  health issues and of course supporting  our frontline workers  we created the moving art community  program as a way for  the entire move for less team to help  families in a meaningful way  to apply for this program go to our  website  at www.moveforlessnevada.com and fill  out the application  all of the dates rules and regulations  will be listed there  you can apply for yourself or nominate  someone else  who is in need for less has been part of  the las vegas community for over 15  years  and we believe in helping out wherever  we can